[Music]
that's a perfect song for this segment
more than three million people have
visited the Smithsonian's National
Museum of african-american history and
culture since it opened nearly two years
ago and it is still one of the most
popular museums on the mall we were
there in Washington for the opening dr.
Martin Luther King Junior's last visit
to Memphis where he was assassinated
fifty years ago is one of the many
stories this museum tells Lonnie bunch
is a museum director and joins us at the
table once again to discuss it's so good
to see you long to see you thank you
I've heard you describe dr. King as a
brilliant strategist what is it about
his legacy that you think that we still
don't really understand or know I think
people sometimes think that civil rights
was going to happen and that King really
came up with brilliant strategies to use
the media when to confront the law when
to break the law so in essence King was
really someone who didn't just March he
created a movement that revolutionized
America in unfinished revolution but a
revolution nonetheless he thought
protest was patriotic did he not I've
always thought that his greatest legacy
is a simple fact that King reminded us
that protest is the highest form of
patriotism that you love a country that
you then do everything you can to help
it live up to its stated ideals it's
interesting you talk about his legacy
because earlier in the week CBS News had
an exclusive sit-down with his children
the first time they were all together
and over a decade and they are worried
that their father's legacy is being
dumbed down what do you think about that
I think in some ways by creating
monuments we do make the rough edges of
history smooth we forget that King stret
was stressed by the work he had to do
you forget that there were losses as
well as victories but I think what you
really realize is that new generations
are I think looking to King to say how
do you change a country in a non-violent
way but in a profound way so I don't
think his legacy is threatened right now
what is the lesson for people who just
see this as a monument I mean take the
actionable item for young for young
people today we're trying to change
things I think the notion that you can
change a country I think that's what's
important King left
a sense of hope that it is possible
despite the odds to do something no one
believed and that's why I think it's so
powerful to see these young kids who
were involved in the March for our lives
reaching back the king having King's
granddaughter suddenly realising you can
find a way to change a country and he
believed in a country Lonnie that often
didn't believe in him I think that's the
greatest strength of candidly
african-american history is you have
people who love a country who want to
see the country live up to its stated
ideals but that country didn't believe
in them and yet they didn't despair they
continued to work to say America's
greatest strength is living up to its
ideals but we have to help America get
there it was interesting in James
Brown's piece where the the choir
members said when he walked in the room
we looked at him in awe and I'm
wondering I will take Barack Obama out
of this conversation because I've seen
black and white people when he walks in
the room they're in awe do you see any
leader since King that can motivate
people the way that he did is there
anybody without without naming a name if
you can do that or if you want to name a
name but but have you seen anybody or
anything there was there's no Martin
Luther King I mean no one had his
charisma his sense of strategy his sense
of being able to cross many lines what
we have are leaders that lead in certain
areas but we don't have a national
leader and I think the world has changed
social media makes it harder for
national leaders and gives local people
more power and so in some ways I don't
think we'll have another Martin Luther
King you know CBS did a poll recently
and only 53 percent of Americans believe
or I should say 53 percent of America
Americans believe only some of his goals
were achieved if he were alive today
this is a historian sorry to ask this
question but if he were alive today what
would he feel about the state of things
on the one hand I think King would say
things have changed a look at the number
of black elected officials look at the
number of African Americans who graduate
college look at the black middle-class
but on the other hand I think he would
worry that we still see black lives not
mattering the way they should
we still see Erb
settings that look like 1968 that
there's not a sense of hope and I think
he would really despair the fact that he
doesn't see a unified sense of helping
America become the Beloved Community
worrying about war worrying about
fairness so I think the lack of economic
justice would be something he'd be very
concerned and here we are 50 years later
and talking about the magnitude of what
he contributed to the country how do we
ensure that fifty and a hundred and
fifty years from now that that our
children will still know what sacrifice
this man made for this country I think
what we need to do is continue to use
museums and education to make sure he's
not forgotten but to make sure that we
tell all the rough edges I mean the
notion that King struggled and stumbled
and fought hard and was still victorious
is a lesson for us all it's a big day at
the museum because starting today on
Wednesdays you're gonna have no past
Wednesday which means what which means
that people for groups under ten people
can come in and just walk in without a
pass I'm so excited about Wednesday just
on Wednesdays in April okay all right so
many people want to come I hope that
works and leads to know passes every day
we will have continuing coverage from
Memphis of the 50th anniversary of the
King assassination on our streaming
network that CBS n and tonight of course
on the CBS Evening News with Jeff Glor
special correspondent James Brown will
lead the coverage all day